*in matpat's most majestic voice*
Do you want to hear a Theory?
Frozen 2 is coming soon
The trailer dropped and I was stunned
It looks so much fun this moment's opportune
To figure out its symbols
Crystals and waves
Whats with the autumn leeeeeeeeeeeaves?
Do you want to hear a theory?
Kinda has to be a theory...
Why? Why is it always a theory?
That's the show....
*Film Theory theme plays*
Hello, Internet! Welcome to FILM THEORY!
Where you may or may not actually get to see this episode
because after Elsagate last year,  anything that even mentions building a snowman
is getting the YouTube BAN HAMMER.
That may seem like a joke, but um, it's really...not.
We'll actually see how many views this video gets...
YouTube, just take Elsa's advice and LET IT GO!
Stop holding back the glittering Frozen theory fodder!
The Internet needs this! They NEED to vastly overspeculate about a children's movie
that seems produced explicitly to sell light blue dresses to four-year-olds!
I mean...uh...shuffle, shuffle, uh research, research deep analysis
So today, as you've probably noticed from the title,
I'm tackling a theory in a movie that hasn't come out yet.
Frozen 2.
In fact, this whole theory is just coming
from the Frozen 2 trailer. Which Even though
it's only 1 minute and 52 seconds
it has turned Frozen 2 into the most hyped.
Disney squeal of all time.
We all know how great I am
at interpreting Disney franchise trailers
from all those fantastically accurate
Star Wars theories. So
I'm expectin' today's prediction-theory to go
prettaaay- pretty well
*troll music bc yeh*
In all seriousness though
despite the fact that we only have a little bit of material to work with
It's actually a lot to unpack
It's also worth mentioning that this theory is gonna be
building on the groundwork that's already been
laid forth by some of our theorist brothers  from another channel mother
fellow internet theorists the Super Carlin Brothers
where they venture an interpretation
of the Nordic runes in the trailer
I think a lot of what's been said so far
is spot on but after watching this trailer
twelve times with my face so close to the screen
it would make my optometrist faint
I think that there's quite a bit more to dig in here
then hasn't been talked about yet
so today I'm going to predict the plot of this movie
based on a single trailer because I just don't think
I give the internet quite enough fodder to make fun of me
SO HERE we go
Disney's most anticipated release of the 21st century
based on less than two minutes of footage
GO
First of all, let's catch you up in case you're not one of us weirdos
staring at our screens until we develop cataracts
Elsa finds herself on a stormy desolate  beach
She removes her gloves and shoes
then sprints towards the crashing waves trying to
American Ninja Warrior her way out to sea
she gets a few steps each time with the help of
her ice powers but the waves eventually break up the ice
and send her crashing back down
the REAL theory here though should be on whether her powers
would actually work on ocean water, to begin with
since the freezing point of salt water is actually
lower than that of fresh water
which means that if her powers bring things to 32 degrees
that water ain't staying frozen for long
and that ladies and gentlemen is the magic of SCIENCE
for the record let it be known here
I reserve the right to do that theory should the events of the movie
deem it necessary
meanwhile in Arendelle Anna looks out her window to see
mysterious floating crystals everywhere
by the look on her face, she ain't too happy about it
we get a shot of Kristoff riding Spin with a herd of
reindeer in tow followed by Anna in what appears
to be the same mysterious place as Elsa at the start of the trailer
Elsa shoots some ice at purple fire so it doesn't melt Olaf
we catch a momentary glimpse of a girl in a forest before
a bunch of leaves shoot up off the ground
and take another unknown character with them
ending with the whole gang on a cliff
overlooking an autumnal forest with the mountains in  the distance
the trailer wraps with the title card saying Frozen 2
and some blowing orange leaves on it
and then Anna kills the cameraman
*rip*
press F to pay respects
~THE END~
so what are we to make of all this?
we spend we so much time
with that opening on the beach
That this feels like it's gonna end up being an important place
But anyone who's seen the first Frozen
should be able to tell that this isn't Arendelle
how do we know?
well even though most of the frozen
puts Arendelle in Norway,
a country that has plenty of shore lines that would have beaches,
this is no Norwegian beach.
Norway is known for yellow, white,
or occasionally black sand beaches.
Not for the black, pebble beach
That we're seeing here in the trailer.
There's even a close up of Elsa's feet to explicitly show the pebbles!
Jennifer Lee, the co-director of Frozen 2,